etwas gegen gibt und dass hier braucht
man um das king gibt an zu leitern und
werde ich heute um mich selbst zu meiner
krankheit für löwenbabys album in den
mixer packen und das mit milch trinkt
sollte was im video machte durch ja auch
gar keinen fall zu hause nachmachen okay
wenn man zum nachmachen ist das extrem
gefährlich auf der kippe näher zu kommen
zu einem neuen video okay leute
erkenntnisstand setting die rolle an den
dienst über stimmung heute wird's ernst
ok erst auf einem kanal den letzten
tagen gesehen hab einfach übertrieben
mit dem bild ist davon besessen wenn ich
ein bild video mache das dann eben auf
bekommen
ich bin youtuber ich kann nichts dagegen
machen ich bin vorne und dem billigauto
wirklich video macht und einfach aus dem
mit dreimal so gut geformt wie die
anderen teams dem ansonsten macht er
denkt man sich auch durch eine besser
machen der fokussierte läuft gar nicht
so sehr genau das ist die krankheit ist
die krankheit die zu machen damit man
die jungs bekommen und ich bin von der
krake paul klee piet ob ich bin krank
ich bin von der dgq geilheit befreien
wird uns raus welche kenntnisse der
erste schritt zur besserung und deswegen
haben wir den ersten schritt genommen
war ich der nächste schritt leute ich
hab mich lange geschäftlich ich habe
lange recherchiert was man machen muss
um von dieser krankheit wieder los zu
kommen erklärt und ich habe letzte
gewählt ich habe das ganze internet
durch kräftiges gebiss und ich habe ihm
dazu auf einen artikel gefunden von
einem stammesoberhaupt aus eritrea und
dieses staatsoberhaupt austria hat ist
ein ganzes leben damit beschäftigt wie
es geht um die liebe krankheit
auszutreiben und die habe ich in
verbindung gesetzt und ich leicht nach
diesen fehler gereicht welche
aufgefunden machen musste es gibt nur
eine möglichkeit diese leute etwas gegen
geht und dafür braucht man das ging gibt
anzureichern und war werde ich heute um
mich selbst zu meiner krankheit zu
erlösen
krimis album in den mixer packen und mit
milch zusammen trinkt zweiter kämpfer
für euch aber die einzige möglichkeiten
des ein gegengift dem man sich endlich
konnte ich überlebte
ich kann leute dann machen
ich möchte ich auch kriegst du mich dazu
gedichte zu hause überlegt dieses video
was soll ich sagen ich kann nicht groß
und wir müssen davon loslegen okay ich
habe mir für den fall der fälle hier in
einmal eingestellt natürlich erstmal die
platte pro jahr machen
hast du schon mal von leuten die heute
gemacht haben ja aber die sind nicht
mehr entscheiden oder so also
verständlich nach der krankheit
verständlich aber recht einfach auch
sehr viele leute jetzt zu sagen dass
hier wird es begann im allgäu gab es nur
passen wenn ich jetzt einfach alles hier
entsprechend dem messer das gerät für
meine letzte rettung des klubs wird
aufhören
ich will keine videos machen alle sagen
du musst auf
[Musik]
die läufe der kammer hat ja auch gesagt
dass man nicht mehr braucht und dann
auch noch ein menschliches haar von der
person im adretten muss mein name ist
bis hinweg dass auch noch einmal fast in
die krebskrankheit es verstärken zwei
dinge wechseln wird
keine andere deutsche schafft ihr das
ding es um die ohren gleichgesetzt
[Applaus]
immer noch ein großes stück auslauf
kranke leute
[Musik]
tun
und egal ob halo mafia und schreitet
unter die sachsen nicht in der besserung
erkennen
das sind wie die wirtin morgen leichter
zu doch funktioniert dann in denen
wirklich funktioniert feuchter klatsche
per video das wir noch kapitän auf die
leute in meinem verlag funktioniert aber
es ist ein sehr sehr sehr gefährlich
experimenten die dürfen auf keinen fall
so auto nach machen das in rain zu
unterhaltungszwecken leute sollte auch
gar keinen zwei nachgemacht werden dass
wir das geklärt habe ich wirklich ernst
gemeint 2003 - sein und wissen